welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and as Wolverine his way into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is upcoming
pays for plans our infinity saga
re-watch uncovered some serious clues
Blue team at the existence of Logan and
his adamantium weapons of mass
destruction already hidden in plain
sight evidence beyond that Weapon X
project Exodus detail I've already
talked about at length though that does
factor into my research here and most of
my zoom conversations that oddly lose
their connection shortly thereafter no
details discovered regarding what
conda's mysterious history unanswered
questions of cap shield and Avengers
endgame in the trail of all of these
rare metals all point to one truth the
x-men are already here and the proof is
an old caps puddin let's follow the
vibranium and see how deep this mount
mashenka rabbit hole goes
recently I explored the mystery of
Mjolnir from infinity war an end game to
how its returning and Thor for which I
guess I'll round up on guys conic
campaign here
but equally perplexing is the magic
weapon on the other side of that boom
equation the shield of Captain America
now Tony Stark returned it to Steve
Rogers after he said in civil war that
freak means my daddy's and I'm picking
it home but then in the end game final
battle Thanos shattered the hell out of
it so the last we saw that broken boy he
was strapped to caps arm in the Battle
of Earth until Thanos Javel into the
quantum tunnel and knocked everyone off
their feet and that broken shield got
lost somewhere in the rubble and was
never seen again it was not on caps arm
when he went back to eternal the
Infinity stones so how did old cab get a
new unbroken shield to hand off to Sam
well it depends on how you interpret the
movie's poorly defined and internally
debated time travel logic the
screenwriters would have you believe
that same timeline cap dubbed the shield
out of ice and left his unfrozen caedm
and other self still down there I side
with the directors who say cap lived in
an alternate timeline and came back to
this timeline that makes sense to me
because cap would have come from some
future year of that alternate timeline
when advancements in quantum navigation
had been made so that he'd be able to
move horizontally across the multiverse
instead of vertically through time crap
I'm losing you I'm just saying old cap
came from a timeline in which his shield
could have been reforged from
different material other than the
vibranium the old bottle was made out of
we got a clue that the shield Sam
carries has different properties from
the footage we've seen from the Falcon
Winter Soldier series on Disney Plus Sam
wedges that shield in a tree that's odd
because you know when kept discus dead
around and when her soldiers of war it
would tend to ricochet off surfaces like
if it could bounce off human flesh
why is it now buttoning through tree
bark I believe it is because this is a
new shield composed not out of vibranium
but the official substance of Captain
America shield in the comics that Marvel
now has the licensing rights to use
proto adamantium so what's the
difference well vibranium is the
naturally mined wakandan mineral that
came to earth via the meteorite
adamantium is the man-made alloy of
vibranium and steel it's stronger and
more rigid the vibranium and of
adamantium there are several types but
primary adamantium is what Weapon X used
to form Wolverine skeleton but primary
adamantium was an attempt to recreate
the miracle alloy roto adamantium used
only once in history Captain America's
shield that is why Wolverines claws
cannot cut through cap shield though
they can Pierce pure vibranium now the
MCU established that caps shield
throughout the Infinity Saga was
composed of vibranium an extremely rare
quantity of vibranium outside Wakanda
along with the amounts that ulysses klaw
stole and sold to ultron but as we watch
the infinity saga new details were
discovered about this history of claw
and makanda that could point to how
adamantium could also be scattered
across this planet book talking about
movies like this makes me appreciate the
filmmaking process and now is a better
time than ever to take class to learn
more about this craft and thanks to
Skillshare for sponsoring this video
Skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning with so much to explore real
projects to create and the support of
fellow creatives Skillshare empowers you
to accomplish real growth Skillshare
offers classes designed for real life
you can learn and grow with short
classes that fit any schedule maybe
you're feeling extra anxious right now
skill sure lets you explore classes that
may help you express what you're feeling
through creative self-discovery taking
the creative writing or painting or
Photoshop class can help you
break up the routine of a day spent
indoors they have classes and topics new
rock stars fans will enjoy like
animation film video music production a
glass I want to check out is teach
yourself to draw anything a step-by-step
process taught by Hayden I obey the
class focuses on building a routine of
drawing so you can approve your skills
over time and my skills need some work I
mean I can't really read or write so I
have to stick figures to communicate
with my co-workers and they can't
understand those either skill sure is
curated specifically for learning there
are no ads and they're always watching
new premium classes so you can stay
focused and follow wherever your
creativity takes you and it's less than
ten dollars a month with an annual
subscription the first 1,000 my
subscribers to click the link in the
description will get a two month free
trial of premium membership so that you
can explore your creativity so when we
rewatched age of Ultron something
interesting appeared in Claus file
plaws great-grandfather was a belgian
warlord who was killed by tataka
after trying to annex Wakanda in the
late 19th century and I pointed out how
this was likely a nod to the infamous
real-world Belgian King leopold ii who
committed horrible war crimes in central
africa right near where the fictional
Wakanda is located now also in recent
weeks some unconfirmed reports have
leaked that Wolverine may join the MCU
in a plot involving a combat Nanosuit
from Shuri and Antarctic vibranium
antarctic vibranium is also known as
anti metal it's found in the prehistoric
savage lands hidden in Antarctica and
many are speculating that Antarctic
vibranium or anti metal will be the Imps
to use origin story for adamantium which
yes are different things in the comics
you know the MCU they tend to simplify
things so here's what I think happened
when that vibranium meteorite crashed to
Wakanda in ancient times parts of it
broke up and scattered across the globe
that might have been how Howard Stark
got vibranium from other parts of the
African continent without having to
cross the borders of Wakanda
specifically I believe that one chunk of
that vibranium crashed into Antarctica
and then over the millennia it was
frozen over by Antarctic ice just
nesting there right next to the the
thing spaceship and I believe wakanda's
involvement with that Belgian war
criminal in central Africa in the late
1800s led to that secret nation
expanding outward to a call
atop another rich mineral deposit near
the South Pole a secondary outpost
hidden in the final unclaimed
continental frontier on earth now that
the heart of Africa was being exposed by
Western colonialism they wanted a
secondary refuge hidden in the ice atop
the secondary frozen mountain go with a
different kind of metal while I do think
a trip to a prehistoric Savage Land
might be a bit much for Black Panther -
that's kind of a Phase six kind of thing
there are other signs we could visit
this would Condon Antarctica colony with
rumors that Namor the Submariner will be
revealed as a ruler of a rival hidden
Kingdom under the sea and Marvel
Atlantis's origin is routed near
Antarctica those undersea earthquakes of
Kuwait told Natasha had not to worry
about perhaps it was a territorial war
between these two kingdoms in the South
Atlantic other rumors point to black
panther - revealing Aurora Monroe storm
who is the daughter of a tribal princess
of Kenya and could perhaps be a key ally
to T'Challa and Wakanda during this war
but the mineral at the heart of that
conflict antarctic vibranium may be a
steel alloy that the MCU will call
adamantium the same substance I think is
being used by project Exodus tap the
Oracle grid and ship stuff out of
storage everything from projects Pegasus
Exodus and Goliath aka shields weapon X
to coat the skeleton using nanotech of a
certain regenerative mutant named James
Howlett to become the wolverine history
presented and black panther - but into
that i believe much earlier in the
falcon in the Winter Soldier because
again the cap shield now used by Falcon
is not the same one we've seen before
it's from a different time most likely
at different realities sometime in the
future you know to allow old cap to bend
and games own rules of quantum
entanglement in which Steve Rogers then
that alternate reality not only knew
about what conda's existence from 1940s
onward but would be able to help them in
their coming conflicts like invaders
like Klaw in the early 90s such favors
would likely be rewarded with a shield
forged from a new alloy called proto
adamantium and that is a new shield
handed off to Sam that ends up wedged in
a tree and that my friends is how in
baseball or Marvel could retcon its own
history to introduce
Nahum Weapon X Wolverine storm named war
and the Captain America shield finally
corrected to be composed of its official
substance proto Adam atm comment down
below with your thoughts on this theory
and for more Theory discussions join our
official discord server which you can
join by becoming a patreon at
patreon.com slash new rock stars follow
me on instagram at EA vas follow new
rockstars subscribe for breakdowns of
everything you love and shout out to my
goddaughter Ellie uncle Eric sorry you
won't be able to visit you in Florida
this summer I mean I mean I guess I
could try to fly solo whoa boom you
looking for this
[Music]